let's break it down get somebody who
sees your video for the first time
recommend it to them on youtube they
click through then they watch
eight nine or ten minutes of it and and
your videos are so optimized that
they're watching almost to the end
and then when the video's over or
another video is recommended
they watch another two three four five
six of your videos
that is a viral revolution on youtube my
friend
so the youtube algorithm can sometimes
feel really overwhelming
what matters and how do you actually get
your videos shown in front of the masses
well did you know that youtube actually
gives you the exact things
that you need to know the exact metrics
in order to be able to
master the algorithm in today's video
we're going to go
really deep if you didn't know at think
media we are all about
educating you on how to do youtube right
whether you're just starting or whether
you already have a successful business
and you want to add youtube to your
marketing strategy
well my name is heather torres and
you're listening to the think
media podcast the number one podcast
where we help you build your influence
on youtube
and then take that influence and build a
high impact and a high profit
youtube channel and on today's episode
we're going
back to school that's right we are
taking you into the youtube education
where we're going to share with you the
four metrics that really matter to
youtube
inside of your youtube creator studio is
where you're going to find all this
information
so we're going to walk through all those
numbers i know it can feel overwhelming
and intimidating when you start to open
up your youtube studio and you see all
these graphs and numbers
and you just want to know which ones
matter like which one should you focused
on
and why these ones are so important so
sean who is really the youtube scientist
is going to be diving deep into all of
these different
acronyms and things that you need to
know so get your notebook ready
get your coffee ready and let's dive
into the youtube class for today
[Music]
so what are the four most important
youtube metrics for getting
massive views if you really want to
unlock
the youtube algorithm these are really
the four
levers that are going to get you the
most momentum on youtube right now and
the first one
is ctr that stands for click
through rate now this is
the definition impressions click through
rate measures how often
viewers watched a video after seeing a
registered impression
on youtube what does that mean it means
that before someone can watch
a second or a minute or ten minutes of
your content
they have to actually make a decision to
click
on the video they have to make a
decision to
tap on that thumbnail on that video on
their smartphone
and so um this really starts with
thinking about how can you grab
people's attention with your title with
your thumbnail and with your
topic the goal is to get as high a
click-through rate as possible
and let's define what an impression is
you know if you were to think
sean how do i actually get people to
discover me on youtube in the first
place how do i actually get views when
nobody knows me
of course maybe you have someone off of
the platform on twitter that you can
send a tweet to your video and they go
watch your video
well that's different that's external
traffic maybe you've built up an email
list and you sent an email
hey here's my new video but on the
platform itself
you have to remember youtube will
actually
recommend your video it'll put your
video in front of other people where
on the home page right when you log into
youtube on that first page there's
videos being suggested to you
if you make videos related to other
videos they're watching a particular
video they don't know you yet
they see a video suggested below the
video or on the right side if they're
watching on desktop
well that's what an impression means
it's a chance to see your thumbnail
on their mobile phone on their desktop
and so the click-through rate
is the percentage of people based on the
impression
that click through on your video now
what's a good click-through rate it's
hard to say because it varies
like the wider your range of impressions
like some of our videos get
40 million impressions and have like a
four percent click-through rate
typically as your video is shared wider
the click-through rate is lower
now sometimes you might have a 80
click-through rate because all of your
subscribers click on your video and it
doesn't really get shared maybe outside
of your community if you want a metric
for this one
if you can get over 10 percent your
video is probably gonna pop off
and if your video stays at over 15 on a
click-through rate
um while it keeps being shared to new
people then you might have a viral video
on your hands but when i'm asking myself
man what are the most important metrics
number one is click-through rate
and you should ask how can i get my
click-through rate higher don't even
actually worry about what it is today
measure it and try to make it higher
tomorrow if it's four percent right now
try to get it to 4.5 and think about how
you can optimize your titles to be
really interesting and clickable
thumbnails to be really interesting and
clickable and that you're talking about
the right topics
in your videos that people actually want
to click on the second one is the
average view duration
let's think about this in order okay
they saw your video on the home page
that looks interesting wow that
thumbnail provoked my interest i do want
to learn more about that that does look
funny or entertaining they click on it
now how long do they stay on the video
and watch it number two is a
vd average view duration
so this is the amount of time viewers
spend watching
your video the total amount of time
the higher the number the better so what
this means is your average view duration
could be two minutes four minutes or
eight minutes
but it might be let's say 10 minutes is
the average view duration
but the video could be two hours long
that happens to me a lot on think media
i'll put out a longer video 45 minutes
an hour and i'll get an average view
duration of like 10 or 12 minutes which
is actually amazing
because across youtube the average view
duration
is around four minutes like the amount
of time on the whole platform
there's so many different niches so many
different styles of content
but the average uteration's around four
minutes so eight
ten is crazy and that's sometimes why
longer form content is good
even if people don't stick throughout
the whole thing if they dwell on one of
your videos
longer then youtube loves that fact and
will potentially promote that video
and let's just talk about why that is
you know the reason
average view iteration matters is
youtube wants people to be on the
platform for as long as
possible they want to be able to tell
advertisers that people are
not just watching short cat viral videos
on youtube
but they're actually watching
substantial content and dwelling on
youtube
just like they would dwell on
traditional tv or netflix or disney plus
they want people really spending minutes
on youtube
minutes matter most and so it's the
average amount of time
people spend watching your video and one
trend that you can take from our think
media playbook
is we've been doing some experiments
with some very high impact videos
but they're not very long like we've
made really high impact
three and a half minute videos a four
and a half minute video and the videos
are doing well
but what we've noticed at least in our
niche is that some of our
45 minute videos some of our hour long
videos
that really hold attention are being
promoted more
because youtube wants more minutes
and so something you can experiment with
can you try some
short videos that are really punchy or
can you try some longer form content
and do your best to hold viewers
attention and a tip here on this one
is video editing video editing is a
great way to trim the fluff
and keep viewers attention longer
because it's not just the length of the
video it's like can you hold their
attention
on the video which brings us to number
three of the four most important youtube
metrics
the third one is a pv
what's that stand for average percentage
viewed
all right so average view duration hour
long video
10 minutes it's just the amount of
minutes that on average people are
spending on that video
average percentage viewed is the percent
of completion based off the video length
right so 10 minutes on
a hundred minutes of content is only 10
average percentage viewed but
eight minutes of a 10 minute video is 80
percent of average percentage
viewed this metric matters as well
youtube loves it when people
watch until the end of the video
and what we've been learning and
noticing from our analytics is that both
are good if you have just really long
form content they get a lot of minutes
average view duration great if you also
can have people watching until the end
of the video
also great and this is what we've been
testing with some of these shorter
punchier videos we've been having people
watch 66 average percentage viewed which
if you can get over 50 or 60 percent
you're doing amazing and
we've noticed that that average
percentage viewed also
can have a big impact as you maybe
experiment with youtube shorts
obviously youtube shorts can only be
maximum
60 seconds long and in this case
it's gonna be average percentage viewed
you don't want people just watching five
seconds of your 60 second youtube short
you want them watching until the very
end so that next short
auto plays so that's definitely an
average percentage view
metric the metric to shoot for here
recapping is if you could get a video to
a click-through rate of over 10
if you can get an average view duration
of over eight minutes
and if you can get an average percentage
viewed of over 60 70 percent
of that eight minutes my friend you
assuredly have a viral video on your
hands
especially if that video continues to be
relevant to wider audiences
what do i mean at some point maybe
your niche is underwater basket weaving
and there's only
so many people that are interested in
underwater basket weaving right
and so maybe the click-through rate for
that niche super high
people are loving it and everybody who's
ever raised their hand
by their viewer behavior by the content
they're consuming by the search terms
they're using on youtube
that has expressed interest in
underwater basket weaving
they will probably be recommended your
video because
people that have the intent of wanting
to see underwater basket weaving content
man when they click through on your
video they spend the time they spend
eight minutes plus
10 12 minutes on it and they watch
almost towards the end of the video
youtube's going to keep showing
more people the video this is how
youtube works
and so ask yourself man how can i hold
people's attention longer
and the biggest tip here is trimming the
fluff
trying to take out maybe those dead
spots those boring spots
trying to take out unnecessary parts you
know i don't know if you've ever
you know started a movie that was like
maybe amazing at the beginning
it grabbed your attention but it got so
slow and maybe the plot got confusing
and the story started to get a little
murky and you gave up in the middle of
the movie
it's been very rare for me but there's
been times when sony and i have been
like you know what
like i don't even care like i just i
don't need i don't need to prove
anything to anyone
we don't need to be able to say we
finish this movie let's just give
let's give this one up man there's just
no reason to make it to the end
obviously that can happen a lot on
youtube maybe it starts strong
but it kind of gets weak in the middle
trim the fluff
think about how you can not only keep
people on the platform longer
but also keep them watching till the end
of the video which finally
brings us to number four which this is a
very
little talked about metric that is very
important
and it's avpv
and it stands for average views per
viewer
what this tells you as you dive into
your youtube analytics
on your channel overall it looks at
everyone who watched your youtube
channel
and it says per viewer how many videos
are is the average viewer watching and
this is one that you want to increase
because what this reveals potentially is
if people are just stopping by your
channel
to watch a bit of information or some
search based content
or if they really are going deep with
you and watching
multiple of your videos in a bingeable
session
so this is the average number of views
your channel receive
per viewer in a so in like a 30 day time
period or whatever
time period so again search based
channels like think media and this is
one of the metrics we're trying to work
on
we sometimes have somebody that just
stops by to learn a piece of information
and then they move on
but i kind of think about it like i
recently heard in business
your goal in business is not to make a
sale
your goal in business is to have a
customer like i think about starbucks is
not even my favorite coffee
and but it's a place that it's so
convenient and it's accessible
and i also love it because it's where i
met my wife sonia back when i was
21 i was going to starbucks when i was
studying the bible at a local ministry
school and i would show up at five
o'clock and
not only was that when my coffee
addiction started but that's when my
sonia addiction started because i
started to try to get her attention
eventually we got married and so
starbucks has a real special place in my
heart she worked there for 10
years right and starbucks
has not just made a sale from me over
the last
10 15 years starbucks has made thousands
of dollars for me
i've repeatedly been inside used their
wi-fi
bought green juice there bought the
little egg bites there the bacon
sous-vide eggs come on bought my you
know spinach
feta wrap there i've got my venti ice
waters
i i've repeatedly gone back to starbucks
avpv
is the goal of your youtube channel is
to not just make one sale
but to have a repeated customer and even
if they're watching your content for
free you want people to keep coming back
to your channel
not just watching one video but do they
watch four or five or six or seven
videos
depends on your niche and this is a
challenging metric but if you can
let's break it down get somebody who
sees your video for the first time
recommend it to them on youtube they
click through then they watch
eight nine or ten minutes of it and and
your videos are so optimized that
they're watching almost to the end
and then when the video's over or
another video is recommended
they watch another two three four five
six of your videos
that is a viral revolution on youtube my
friend
definitely easier described than
implemented
but these are the metrics you want to be
thinking about when you think about your
content strategy
when you think about how you're creating
content
and how you can improve your videos and
the biggest thing here
is creating bingeable content that is on
brand creating content that is
not just one-off topics but that has a
cohesive theme that people want to watch
part one part two part three
or they wanna keep coming back and
watching more
this makes me think that sometimes maybe
it's easier for to do on a
personality-based channel because once
you fall in love with that personality
you want to watch more personality from
that person i think about comedians that
i like like
john crist where he does a show every
week called one take
and so every week i watch one take and
so in a 30 day period i think he's
getting at least
four views from me because i just keep
watching his
show phil defranco pretty much watch
that multiple different
shows because he's the common
denominator
of that my wife and i love the show
daily dose of the internet
and it's these little quick bite-sized
videos that are about four minutes long
we don't just watch one video on that
channel we could easily crush
one two three four five of those so i
would imagine their avpv
is pretty big and they're getting
millions of videos a day on their video
on their
videos so definitely something to pay
attention to so how can you increase
your ctr your avd your apv
and your avpv you may want to replay the
video
because i know those are some acronyms
that are coming at you quick and your
youtube education just went to a whole
nother level
knowing four metrics which will
absolutely help you grow
as you dial these in let's summarize and
talk about
a lit you know make this a little more
practical with how overwhelming this
could
sound summary point number one
goal is just to get one percent better
with every upload you might be like sean
i barely know how to make a thumbnail
like video editing video editing
intimidates me
you know how do i get average views per
viewer i
barely have any viewers yet listen
youtube's all about starting messy
punching fear in the face but then
getting one percent better with every
upload and when you have
better insights into how youtube works
it will influence your content
so you can think about man how do i make
the topic catchy the thumbnail catchy
how do i grab attention at the beginning
and keep attention
and then finally point two to summarize
is to keep working on these metrics and
just try to get a little bit better on
each one
it's not about making giant leaps it's
about just making
practical steps little bits of increase
and maybe even honing in on just one i
think trying to even grow in all four
all at once could be overwhelming
but maybe just focus on i want to get
better at thumbnails i want to study
some of the videos on think media
on thumbnails and how to use canva to
make better thumbnails
because as you tweak one area
of your youtube channel and your content
strategy small tweaks lead to giant
peaks
a rising tide lifts all ships if you're
getting better click-through rate you're
getting more viewership
more viewership is leading to more
people watching more videos
and it can become an exponential effect
that maybe starts small
but creates a big snowball of momentum
over time well i hope your notebook is
full
of all the acronyms that you needed to
know and really
all of the metrics that matter on
youtube go back
and re-listen to this episode over and
over if you just want to learn more
about exactly what matters
for the youtube algorithm and if you're
ready to take your next step on youtube
then i highly recommend that you go to
our free
youtube class at thinkmasterclass.com
we're diving into the
three secrets for youtube success and
how you can grow your youtube channel
today so go to thinkmasterclass.com
if you're ready to get started and make
sure that you rate and review this
podcast
over on itunes it means the world to us
when we're able to read your comments
but also it helps us get this podcast in
front of other
purpose-driven entrepreneurs and content
creators
just like you and today's review
comes from sophielu222
she says as a new youtuber think
marketing has been my go-to for the
advice and tools to succeeding on the
platform
forever grateful and love the new
podcast where i can listen
on the go with the cutest emoji girl
dancing
uh yes we are here to help you with the
tools to succeed
on this platform and today's episode was
no different
i hope that you got a lot of value out
of this episode and
i want to encourage you to share it with
a friend i'm sure that you know other
purpose-driven
content creators or people that you know
should be
rocking their youtube channel so share
this podcast with a friend
and i cannot wait to see you in our next
episode
you